foreign
Lakeside town of Chelan Washington to
help a husband and wife repair their bad
reputation they have built walls around
themselves there are absolutely no part
of this community they don't know the
difference between right and wrong
there's no such thing as a fresh burger
what and they are so stubborn you don't
even know the [__] story
it'll be a challenge to get through to
them all you've done since I've arrived
here is lied to me and I totally [__]
disagree with that
yeah
Chilean Washington surrounded by the
gorgeous Cascade Mountains situated on
Lake Chelan this small town is home to
the Lakeview hotel and BC McDonald's
restaurant owners Brenton Anthony
McDonald have been in business here for
over 15 years we bought the hotel in
2000. we came into town and and a lot of
the locals they really didn't want to
see us make it they figured they won't
be here long
well I let them know that we are going
nowhere you're stuck with us the
Lakeview hotel is adults only we think
that it's the nicest hotel probably in
the state of Washington we have
business is really slow we're losing
probably 30 000 a month
easy
the financial situation here at the
hotel in the restaurant it is tough and
this year it's extremely tough because
we had wildfires in the area and quite
honestly that's what kind of has broke
the bank
majority of the reason why there's no
consistent business here is Brent and
acne's reputation and I'm talking I am
talking customers come in and she said
you hurry up you go sit down I'm
training you sit down we'll be with you
a minute
I'm the best employer in town I think
I'm easy to work with just just quiet
will you please you know I don't know
why people don't like to be here if you
want to keep money flowing through the
locals need to like you and you know if
you have a bad attitude towards the
locals or other customers they're not
going to come back
[Music]
out there and do a little Dance come on
I know you used to pole dance get your
ass out there I definitely get very
embarrassed by some of the things he
says I hope you got a lot of energy
tonight because baby this is this is
Friday night Friday night people are
coming to a nice restaurant they don't
want to hear dirty jokes and cussing and
everything like that Brant does not like
to be told anything you can tell him the
sky is blue and he's it's gonna upset I
think that people are lucky to work for
us I think I got a great management
style
[Music]
Chelan is a beautiful town the
opportunity is there
we just get overlooked because of Brent
and Anthony's reputation
all of our money that we have made in
the last 30 years has been sunk into
this business and we have so much
invested we cannot stop because
otherwise we're we're done
[Music]
that was the valley guy
that's him
yeah it's not my eyesight maybe thinks
he has the wrong place
[Music]
L.A parking is not well baby
this is the best breakfast lunch and
dinner in town come on here come on in
how are you good afternoon Chef Ramsay
what a gorgeous drive that was oh thank
you how are you boy ladies first I
totally understand that nice to see you
um are we uh the valley parking on
strike it is this time of year so it's
temporary ballet parking I want to do my
car because you kept the sign there I'll
park it for you how about that wow
was the last time we dusted the hairs
but Dusty
what's that there
something is growing up there can you
see that or is it me I can see it wow
yeah I know you both wearing glasses I
just want to make sure you can see it
it's now it's not real easy to see for
me how did you get that down
[Music]
back here
I'll be right back
wow now you've made everything Dusty
down here I've made it Dusty no you
haven't cleaned it yeah supposing that
falls on a customer's head what would
you do
I don't think that it will actually but
you don't think it will no well it's
been up there for about six months it
seems to be growing actually nice
disgusting yeah Brett shame on you I
know it wow and what's in here
more dust over here bro look is there
more you must have missed that spot too
there's a big long creepy crawler
hanging down yes I see that wow we've
been closed for the last three weeks
when it's so slow this time of the year
we go on a holiday and when you close do
you normally clean before you close
would you come back dirt
come back the way it is and wow look at
that up there we're living in a very
dusty environment here that's [__]
yeah okay uh come on seriously this is
the mountain clean air well that's all
true yeah oh there you go yeah there we
go thank you for that no problem I
didn't expect to clean as I checked in
like oh my god there you go they are
gross right you're not messing up too
much it's all going to come down well
how long are you thinking of keeping up
there
we might as well do them all while we're
at it we might as well do them all yeah
it's not funny I've got to get this
thing out here
holy [__] look at that
[__] damn it Daphne why didn't you get
to that
and how long have you owned this place
15 15 years 15 years last time it was
clean it was clean you're just good I
was you've got a great eye
I've done lots of things on arrival but
I've never quite cleaned
[__] like that from a scene can I give
that back to you I'll do that okay right
yeah
um what's going on here on the front
door you've got 40 flavors yes so no
samples yes when we're really really
busy we have a line that goes out the
door again
one person asked for uh a sample they
will all ask for example and how do you
think all those yogurt franchises entice
business
Alpha samples
so they speculate to accumulate
Sino samples sorry no samples who comes
up with all these stupid rules it's
probably myself man you like kicking the
crap out the locals don't you yes
so I take it we're not going to get oh
there's another one yes there's me
thinking that's a flavor
so how long ago did this close oh my god
look how dusty that is it's not closed
this is not closed no it's not stop it
is not it looks like it's oh no
Lati how where's the stick gone please
oh my God this is monstrous this is like
a cobweb on steroids where's the stick
gone she's getting it so why did you
close for three weeks
I went on a holiday wow and where did
you go Mexico wow did you enjoy Mexico
she only came for a week she gives me a
week by myself
say that again you go on holiday on your
own I do rest for a week and your wife
comes from my wife and daughter meet me
for the second week he's not like to go
for two weeks holiday well I would love
to if I have a chance I see
right
um I just want to get this thing down
here have you seen the size of this one
yeah holy crap is that a keeper that
look at that this is above a nice cream
parlor if we turn that on it's gonna
spin dust hopefully it won't for that
yeah that is
what I I think you're doing awesome
actually I I think that we should
possibly hire him really you know I'm
glad that I'm hired to clean yeah
wow would you like to take this to my
room it may be a good idea are you
serious no let's go no dust right oh
[__] whilst I'm up here look oh come on
now but look at these ones here on the
top of that we'll get it oh now you'll
get it
well it's obvious that you haven't done
it before you know how many rooms you
have here 12 12. wow this room probably
isn't for you but we're gonna give it to
you anyway what'd you mean by that it's
for people that haven't been laid for a
while quite honestly say that again
sorry
people that haven't been late laid
played as in as in what's that got to do
with me checking into this room
yeah wow and this is a room for those
who haven't been laid recently you don't
talk like that to guests well this is an
awesome room it offers the best view
that we have of the river part of Lake
Chelan well wow has a stack stone
fireplace awesome ceiling I think
they're 15 feet and uh awesome Dusty
ceiling see those Beams I can see yeah I
see that a little bit man what is it
with dust around here well as I said
we're in a Dusty area
apart from the dust the rooms are
gorgeous yes these are the air
conditioning uh units where's that so
you don't have that funky thing down
here that cries Motel I thought it was
TV no it's uh air conditioning it's both
we program it for both AC or right so
where do I adjust the temperature uh you
don't they're precept it's set at 68
degrees wow why is it set like that I
keep the remote controls because I
absolutely know that they will get
screwed up if I leave them up here in
the room you don't give samples you
don't let me keep the remotes and you
don't let me bring the temperature up or
down it's not really the get laid room
is it
that's up to you wow you're set in the
bar you're telling me what I can and
what I can't do weird very weird look
how dusty this is as well how do I open
that up
to get all these photos yes please thank
you
wow when was the last time they were
cleaned it gets cleaned about twice a
year
uh would you mind if I just make it
three times this year yeah I think that
sounds great actually
so the air conditioning unit you control
they have to breathe in this [__] at
night are you bullshitting me
right can you uh I will take that do you
mind I've got no interest in breathing
your ass
okay I'm gonna unpack and I'll be down
in five minutes okay please wow
honestly look at that
[Music]
man um the dust when I walked in what
the hell was going on there
bizarre how long have you been here a
month so you're a new kid on the Block I
am I guess wow do they go through a lot
of stuff I think so there is some that
have been here for years but actually
the ones that were here the cooks they
have recently left and I mean how would
you describe them as bosses
um
different than any I've ever had yeah
outside anyway let's order
um obviously I was gonna have a glass of
wine hoping to get something local
having just driven through those amazing
Vineyards but there's nothing local yeah
no I mean New Zealand sauvignon blanc
what would you recommend for lunch
what's the soup today the soup is a
minestrone oh that's good yeah BC's
bacon burger yeah okay let's do a pizza
as well right sorry actually we don't do
the pizzas any longer I don't know why
the page is not taken out wow okay uh
anything else that's not on we are out
of the pork stir-fry and we do not have
chili uh no chili no
let's do a prime rib as well with that
shall we
um I believe we're out of Premium
all right we're out I believe so yeah
the um turkey ciabatta dip it's usually
a good one let's do a turkey dip okay um
hold on a minute breaking news BC soon
to be famous Cherokee steak what the
[__] does that mean when someone says
soon to be famous who writes this [__]
on the menu famous won't that be on the
menu I think we should try it let's go
um I think we're done okay yeah sure
yeah thank you
okay do you need help
minestrone soup right correct
wow that doesn't even chase homemade
it's frozen
Frozen
Frozen minestrone soup yeah okay this is
terrible
you've got the BC bacon burger
wow jeez look how thin that is my onion
rings thicker than my Pate
huh where are they from
yeah I'll find out that answer
on the hamburgers it says on the menu
certified Angus beef where do we get
that are they fresh or frozen no we we
always come back that's frozen
the Pate is Bland it actually tastes
Frozen
it does come Frozen
so it says fresh and it's not anywhere
near 13 for that
is
the food coming out it's very good this
is the turkey milk thank you and what's
this here that is the broth for the
turkey
if you want to end up here sandwich in
it
wow so salty yes it's so bad it's salty
and bitter she's you want to taste this
actually he had me tasted oh yeah it's
really salty really salty yeah holy [__]
this year is the teriyaki chicken burger
nearly famous burger
doused in
turkey over cheese
oh nearly famous this is bad to be
famous to send me
to the bathroom yeah I mean I'm gonna go
there nope
I'll just have a coffee okay
right
reviewing
wow headline do not go here if you want
mediocre overpriced food this is the
place for you unfortunately not my dig
bloody hell
it's terrible this is terrible oh it's
awful I mean look at the headlines what
are not place the owner Batman or
another local place at our table do not
go here run run run far away horrible
service terrible food and stupid
expensive the owners are jerks who are
rude and don't support their staff they
don't welcome kids no wonder this place
is empty isn't that bad
it is it's very awkward you know Anthony
says they don't listen to this these are
customers they're all negative and FYI
no samples allowed that's right it's a
tight bastard yeah is he really stingy
absolutely yeah and the lack of you know
children and they do have a teenage
daughter so they have a teenage daughter
but they don't welcome kids yes
he goes on holiday for a week on his own
Sons himself gets nice and bronzed then
she joins him for the second week but he
wants a week on his own
yeah what a creep yeah if I did that to
my wife she'd kick me in the nuts yes
I'm at a loss this place is depressing
I'd like to get the owners down here
let's just have a little debris shall we
okay
wow Jesus
they want us he does
let's go it's okay
you think that is not stop it
[Music]
I'm at a loss the biggest kicking the
ball for me is that on the menu it
states homemade
fresh daily changing soup of the day
your soup of the day
Brent is Frozen
can you make minestrone soup yes how
much does it cost to make a liter a
couple bucks tell the owner and you have
the nearly famous burger I'd like to
congratulate you because it's now famous
as the most disgusting bit of [__]
between a bun I've ever seen
you have a slice of red onion that's
thicker than your Pate it was frozen and
you're charging 13.95 for it I don't
know how low we can go
the list everything's from New Zealand
there's not even a local wine on here
well give it to me then well I'll give
it to you
most of these wineries all opened up
restaurants
there are competitors so you can't
support a local Vineyard well
I came in here to help
I'm laughed at lied to and fed frozen
food
as an owner you too can't be that gone
otherwise I'm gonna go
[Music]
right before dinner I had a chance to
catch up with Teddy the manager so I
could understand his perspective of what
Anthony and Brent are like as owners
inappropriate things are commonly said
his personality has a lot to do with it
it's you know really common that he'll
make you feel that this is the best
place and you're lucky to be here their
behavior as bosses is unacceptable wow
wow wow clearly in denial I appreciate
the Insight yeah awesome thank you thank
you I'll see you in there yes definitely
and I want to observe what they're like
during an evening at the lake view
so you have a key to the room but let's
hope that it's ready a couple things
that we're not offering no Chilean sea
bass no pizza so no pizza no pizza no
sea bass very disappointing
[__] you know Frozen Frozen
wow I'm not even wrapped where are the
burgers I mean it just doesn't look
anything like a burger and when it's
processed like that and stamped and
pressed you can just tell right frozen
food wow Craig come with me yeah how's
the fettuccine okay
not the best
um burgers
a burger cooked here locally would you
expect that to be frozen or fresh
the burger is not frozen it's the
patties and everything come in for us
and we're thought out is that like most
people just sort it out so it's not
frozen then it comes in Frozen
you thought out and that to the your
customers is not a frozen Burger
well
stay there let me just show you
something
[Music]
I'm waiting for him to come back he's
gonna ring me on something oh boy here
we go
so there's your Burgers it's a frozen
thank you
now your husband said it wasn't
no what do you mean no it's it's frozen
of course I never said that it wasn't it
we thought out here it comes in Frozen
yeah
it's still a frozen Burger there's no
such thing as a fresh burger at least at
least here in Eastern Washington we
cannot get fresh there's no fruit you
find me the Burger come with me yeah
good evening welcome please come in out
the cold dinner quick question do you
love a burger
yes would you expect them to be made
fresh here or frozen fresh
you're gonna tell them what should I
tell them
fresh all the way no should we tell them
the truth I mean that's what we wanted
well we we still uh our Burgers come in
Frozen and we thaw them out but thawing
them out doesn't make them fresh
thank you appreciate it thank you thank
you thanks for coming you guys welcome
ladies hey folks how are you quick
question coming out for dinner would you
expect a frozen Burger to be served here
tonight or a fresh one fresh fresh
you're gonna tell them what should I
tell them I'll let you tell him oh come
on you earned the place well we all of
our beef that we get in Burgers it comes
in Frozen our burgers and we and we thaw
them out which in his mind convinces him
it's fresh does that make it sound any
better no thank you
we're still glad to have you thank you
you bet oh my God
after Brent tried to convince me that
there were no fresh burgers in town I
almost cry it's okay you did good huh
I'm proud of you I walked directly
across the street and ordered one so
that's the lamb burger
[Music]
nice to see you coming to a restaurant
like this would you expect your Burgers
to be fresh or frozen fresh Burgers come
in Frozen and we thaw them out
that's the story thank you
so that is a lamb burger
fresh I'm getting sick to death of this
denial denial denial you've been making
up [__] all [__] day yes you have
all your staff are the same thing to say
passive aggressive condescending
inappropriate and stubborn
oh absolutely not the staff the way you
treat them what there you go again
no no no
you're just scared about employing your
team that's going to tell you the truth
that is [__] that is not because you
don't like them confronting you with the
truth yes you'll fire them no I haven't
found anybody I heard that you fired
your son
oh [__]
you don't even know the [__] story he
was having some issues Gordon and I told
him heard the alcohol problem I was
aware of that right I was trying to save
his life yeah my brother's a drug addict
we put him in rehab seven times
unsuccessfully I don't give up on him
but what I'm more concerned about is
that nothing's affecting you it's like
we're doing great in in generally the
place runs quite well
oh my God
come with me just yeah you and I
is this a joke for you you know it's two
minutes please no he says are you
[__] around no I'm not [__] are
you trying to pull the ball out of my
eyes oh hell no you know the business is
dwindling so you've got all these rules
no [__] samples no [__] kids this
place is thriving with families we
really don't want to have crying kids
here I just I just would like to have a
quiet get away for for our Honeymooners
and and birthdays and anniversaries a
honeymoon Venture they come down a
romantic dinner and eat a frozen Burger
come on this place is hemorrhaging money
because you're caught in a web it's
delusional stubborn
old-fashioned
and [__] pompous
anything else
it's just a joke for you isn't it no I'm
just next time I'm gonna know to do a
little dusting
a little dusting [__] my other looted
[Music]
during dinner service I decided to do
some investigating in the rooms
and after what I found I gathered the
hotel guests along with Anthony and
Brent hey guys come through please
um just very quickly glass is on
here we are come through if you just
stand over here pillow left hand side
pillow number one
can you see that I can't see it you
can't see maybe Anthony yeah explain to
Brent what this is uh spot
you don't know yes but maybe this one
will be a little bit clearer
blood
yeah there we go honey well that's
disgusting right acne yes Brent can't
see anything I I uh go ahead where I see
that of course okay
this is the worrying bit these are the
duvets that have been on these beds that
was just washed one week ago every
single one of them Absolute rubbish and
look at this
I mean these customers they're the ones
you're taking the money from don't you
dare tell me that was washed a week ago
a week ago
you cannot be serious we are serious it
was done and that's that's it we're not
gonna say that
it's not clear that's [__]
[Music]
but one week ago that was cleaned I'm
done with this [__]
we did 13 of them one week ago and
they're not cleaning them properly stop
just for once today [__] lying
[Music]
and look at this
I mean that is not clean that was just
washed one week ago stop just for once
today lying let's stay here two seconds
[Music]
did you have any idea you're sleeping in
that
no not at all I wish you can't see that
I couldn't sleep in that Brent
I I see that I want an explanation
because all you've done since I've
arrived here is lied to me lie to me lie
to your staff and I am not going to
allow you to lie to the customers
and I totally [__] disagree with that
too I have not said one lie to you if
I'm not gonna go for that yes you have
no idea
it's not true you convinced that thought
food is fresh food
you're robbing them of their cash you're
telling me this was cleaned a week ago
let me ask you a question in front of
your customers would you sleep on that
no so why'd you expect them to would you
sleep on that no
not an apology nothing
I'd like to apologize I'm I'm appalled
I'm disgusted
I've had enough
anything you'd like to say
the pillows like this I apologize
can I have a word with him on my own
would you mind
these guests are hours away from putting
their heads on your pillows
Blood Stained pillows
semen stained duvet covers
and sweat
accumulated over years I I can see that
Gordon
I am struggling I'm struggling with your
husband that's in denial I'm struggling
with these arrogance and I'm struggling
with these blatant lies I'm not here to
butt heads with a liar I'm here to help
turn this business around
happening you can talk to me are you
worried about Brent
he's my husband
's my life
we have daughter together
does your daughter feel this at home
and he fell out with his son
he fired his son
yeah does that still bother him
is that what it is
still his son
of course he's still his son he's still
care about him it doesn't sound like
he's caring about him
the guy was drinking
he needed help
so he got rid of him
is that what's bothering him is that why
he's in denial I need Brent to take his
guard down something inside here is
bothering him
I don't know if it's the financial debt
the pressure is it his son I don't know
I can't get in
I want to talk to his son
how can I get hold of him I got his
number thank you
Anthony
You're the Only Hope I've got
can we work together yeah and can we get
him to open up
okay and tomorrow morning I want the
truth and nothing but the truth
okay
[Music]
I really needed to break through to
Brent and to see why he is so stubborn
so my team and I attempted to get hold
of his son to meet me at the hotel but
we were unsuccessful now is up to me to
try to get through to Brent
[Music]
let's take a seat at the bar I've got to
get through to you why are you so
stubborn you got [__] off last night I
mentioned your son
why did that hit a nerve
you know we just had a breakdown in the
relationship when his when his mom
remarried uh they she remarried the same
day the divorce was Final so party
company with a son
you weren't even present at your
daughter's wedding I
I was not invited I didn't even know she
got married
I was destroyed everybody wants to see
their daughter
[Music]
three doses
that's painful
you know when you're when your kids tell
you
I don't know well
I have three grandkids
I have him seen two of them
you know what you know I am stubborn
maybe I'm stubborn but when you get shut
off and then your mom died I thought wow
maybe this is going to be my chance and
maybe they're going to come to me
you're still their father
you're still their dad I know it
can't go around with that that that
that anger I I I've been waiting for
them to come to me
instead instead of the other that's
never gonna happen yeah well that's
that's my proudness and my stubbornness
you know
you have to change your ways and you
have to start becoming a lot more
generous as an owner as a father
responsible for three kids and I I'm not
here to fix your family I'd love you too
I would so [__] love you too
and just you calling them make an effort
they need to see the change but you need
to embrace that I agree there's too much
to say
reach out to those kids you've got to
bring those barriers down and you've got
to open up and somewhere in there
there's the friendly comforting
supportive you know astute Brent we've
got to get back there
Brent and acne's bad reputation within
the town comes as no surprise you've got
a picture there great give me two
minutes please okay I've gathered local
business owners to show Brent and afley
the issues they don't realize they have
good morning good morning how are we
good first of all I just want to say a
big thank you for coming you guys are
the pillars of the community you have
businesses and you are very proud of
what you've built here and I've been
struggling trying to get through to
Brent he's in denial I feel like
Brent is an Undertaker those people that
are working for him there aren't many
that have very good things to say wow
tickets
I had a friend that used to work here at
BC's and she had a customer that had a
steak dinner and her baked potato it was
all great and he wanted to take it with
him so she took it in the back and set
it on the counter and went to get it to
go container and acne
scraped it into the garbage and she said
would uh my customer kind of wanted to
take that and she watched Avenue grab
the baked potato wipe it off and grab
the stuff and she made her give that to
the customer no
bye
no free samples on the ice creams how
hard is it to give somebody a little
plastic spoon
what do they give back to the town there
are absolutely no part of this community
they have built walls around themselves
and you need to take care of each other
in the off season it's locals taking
care of locals
and I don't think I can remember them
offering help in any way it was a crisis
that everybody found a need and
everybody helped yeah except that accept
them
Spirit of Chelan I think is what we're
getting at we share tractors we share
you know from Vineyard work to some of
us have restaurants so we share
employees it's oblivious
how come there's no wine
from this amazing region on their list
when we first started our Winery his
excuse was that the wineries have
restaurants that compete with his
restaurant in addition to that it would
be a shame if there was just one good
place in town to go to we want tourists
to come here and have a great time
everywhere they go so if if he does well
we'll all do well
I really appreciate the feedback but I
want you to help me get through them on
another level now because I'm going to
go and get them
and we're going to tackle this head on
uh give me two minutes thank you so much
really a really high
trial really
hi hi folks these are in my Minds
even more important than customers
because you guys should be bonded
clearly you're not
why is it taking so long
sometimes you need somebody to slap your
face
we were in a comfort zone somewhat
and used to the way we did everything
you know for a lot of years and it needs
to be changed maybe we banked on the
location too much
there's a lot of things we've done wrong
the desperate to see you do well
anything to say there can never be too
many fun
good places in town we always want
somewhere to go and relax and enjoy
ourselves I think we all want you back
on our radar
all of this has been a wake-up call for
us this is part of the reason why we
asked Chef Ramsey to come to help us
we're listening we heard everything that
you had to say
and we are going to try to do much much
better we're hearing you I don't think
that I knew how the business Community
was connected that everybody is feeding
off of each other we have to realize
that to be part of this connection we
have to change
Brent and Anthony committing to change
my team moved forward getting rid of all
the dust and cobwebs we furnished all
the rooms with brand new bedding but the
biggest change was overhauling the ice
cream parlor
off you go ladies welcome
wow unbelievable unbelievable this is
what I call a parlor if you had a
dreadful space here yes oh my God now
it's turned into something magical do
you think there's any chance that I can
get a sample we will be throwing samples
out everywhere
this is way beyond our expectation
[Music]
given the importance of the local
wineries I brought in familiar Dave Foss
how are you who repaired the bad
reputations with the locals that Brent
and acne had you're going to need to
nurture those relationships and he
created a brand new menu featuring all
Washington wine you're no longer going
to have to say sorry I don't have any
local wines finally to accompany all
this I created a small and more exciting
menu that features all fresh food dig in
have a little taste
God
everything fresh better fantastic
what I have learned from this community
is that local support is everything and
this town is willing to give Brent and
athlete a second chance hi sir everybody
how are you today good to see you guys
would you like to see my new ice cream
parlor here with all the new
improvements I'm hoping Brent and affle
make a good impression for the people of
Chelan I actually brought you a list of
a lot of purveyors that we work with
cool oh you want to check in
how are you guys
the hotel is booked up this is just
gorgeous and the guests will sleep well
tonight in the brand new bedding we've
added to all the rooms
there's a real Buzz about the new menu
Margaret and the kitchen is easily
executing the dishes a quiche
a chicken sandwich and I got the salmon
what we're trying to do is just focus on
the local wineries with the help of
similar Dave Foss the customers are
pleased with a local selection of wines
they're offering at BC McDonald's you
like that
I'm always making a mess that's the idea
I'm the official scooper the ice cream
shop is a hit and Brent is even happy
giving away samples if you drop it on
the floor you own it right
everything is Success I'm hoping Brent
makes one important rule change with
this hotel have you thought about what I
mentioned about with children regarding
children in the hotel or you're still
sticking with no children you know what
I'm going to stick to the adults only
adults only
why well look at you take two or three
or four children up there and I'm gonna
tell you they wipe out the whole damn
place what the noise noise crying
whatever uh gum
uh pop and God forbid samples of ice
cream they will have a young daughter I
know I'm talking three four eight year
old have you asked yourself the concert
you know what am I missing on turnover
Revenue we may miss a few but I think we
miss a few on the other end if there
were two or three kids running down the
hall but not every every kid is is that
noisy I mean just trying to be open with
maybe a couple things I will give it
five that's a tough one
[Music]
I'm disappointed Brent went altery's
rules about allowing kids at the hotel
but hopefully after seeing the success
of the relaunch he'll change his mind
keep up the good work yes Ryan do not
let him go back absolutely not okay well
done thank you
are you living yes
yes everybody now in this town is
rallying around for your success yes so
embrace it watching you stand behind
that counter just giving samples out and
seeing the light on the kids face that
is extraordinary that's awesome please
don't go back
there's an amazing guy underneath all
those layers there is yes there is I'm
just there is thank you there is you can
do this okay I can do it yeah take care
thank you so much okay and he's going to
think about getting some kids in here
okay okay yeah
I'm serious Mr stubborn okay
a couple scoops of ice cream goes a long
way oh boy it's really gone down hasn't
it
okay thank you take care good night okay
bye-bye
despite my help with the Outreach of the
community
Brent quickly reverted back to his old
ways
distancing himself from the locals
much of the staff have left or been
fired and the hotel's reputation within
the town has only gotten worse
[__]
I don't I don't know where in the hell
everybody's at
[Music]
I'm checking into a very unusual
location
a castle in the middle of Ohio run by a
mother and son you know you get a little
overwhelmed and you don't know how to
proceed she takes on all the
responsibility have you ever told anyone
how much stress is on your shoulders no
I pretty much keep it in and he doesn't
know how to help I can't tell you a
business-wise if Jimmy really has any
strengths at this point if I can't get
through to him this hotel will be in
serious Jeopardy surely you must know
that this is not right no
no
[Music]
located along the Black Fork of the
Mohican river is the small town of
Loudonville home to landol's Mohican
Castle
[Music]
after selling their profitable printing
business owner Jim and Martin Landoll
built the castle on a lush 1100 Acre
state in the heart of rural Ohio Jim and
I ran a coloring book publishing
business we did sell it I assumed we
would retire but Jim had other ideas
my dad told himself that if he ever made
any kind of money someday he would build
a castle and he made money and built a
castle
between the castle and restaurant the
official total was in the six million
dollar range
in 2008 our beautiful restaurant burned
to the ground
my husband he had let the insurance
lapse unfortunately it was only four
days prior
it was a very really bad day
[Music]
we burned down in May and Jim and I
separated in June we were divorced
within the year Jim retired and now it's
all on my shoulders
Marta does everything here she works oh
my gosh harder than anybody I think on
the property
she runs around like crazy there's not a
day that she's not working from Sun up
until sundown
she could be retired she could be
relaxing somewhere enjoying her
grandkids but instead it's almost like
she's a prisoner here so
I think that we really need Jimmy
to manage the property
Jimmy's the general manager in title
only he's more the cook here on the
property it says two or one tablespoon
of Worcestershire or whatever you call
it we don't really honestly take him
seriously but
we've never had a reason to I guess take
him seriously are we supposed to clean
up now because he's the baby born with a
silver spoon in his mouth that
everybody's always done everything for
him what is honey glazed carrots I've
actually never made those Marta does
baby Jimmy and that causes Jimmy to not
really have to step up and be a general
manager
[Music]
we keep thinking what what can we do
what can we do to get more you know more
customers in the restaurant what can we
do to get more people at the hotel it
has such potential
one of my main concerns is that I do
want to be able to make this place
successful and be able to
retire but it is a struggle you know
because a lot of times I don't see a lot
of light at the end of the tunnel
[Music]
I'm here in Ohio I'm heading to a castle
that's right a castle but it's actually
built by a local businessman he's no
longer involved and he's left the
property to his ex-wife and his son to
run
we are a castle up ahead for that wow
the crayons are stunning
OMG look at this place what an amazing
setup really beautiful
[Music]
hello hello my goodness me
of corn nice to see you nice to meet you
um this place is incredible when was it
built they started Construction in 1996
we opened in 2002. well how long have
you been here I've been here for 10
years and all this sort of
junk what happens to that stuff this is
our little gift shop oh wow
yeah so this is a gift shop bits of sort
of knickknacks and just yeah
but they seem hard what about these I
haven't saw any of the reading
sunglasses and what's that
that is the CD we have in our rooms the
CD well the Celtic Mystique we have
music playing on our Suites when you
arrive wow um I didn't know people buy
CDs anymore
wow 16. is it good
I've listened to it for 10 years I don't
hear it anymore most of the time what a
strange little knick-knack shop and
what's over here
um oh the beer and wine that we sell
well you see the dust on top of there
everything's so dusty who's in charge of
cleaning I'm slacking on my job I
appreciate the odd speckle of dust on
the wine The Wine Cellar but not not
like this wow and look at that when is
that from
1981. you laugh but it is a little out
of date right oh yeah definitely out of
date and Dusty Dusty the actual TV was
on you couldn't see it because of the
Dust
um so it looks like it was high-end to
build really expensive but yes it
doesn't look like we've had enough money
going back into it to keep it sort of
where how where it needs to be where
their house should be right and what's
over here
they do 30 to 15 a year who runs those
Melody is our events coordinator and
she's a specialist in events and
um she was never like trained or
anything but she couldn't run events if
you're not being trained common sense
sometimes prevails now what's that there
land knows Mohegan Castle win a night
stay stop you know how many people want
a free night seriously seriously yeah we
try to do it once a month should I do
one yes please
[Music]
love this love it ready so
all right that's fantastic you know is
there a cell number on there
um
thank you
answer machine
Chuck congratulations you have won
yourself a free night stay at landoll's
Mohican Castle courtesy of me Gordon
Ramsay free dinner
no it's not included no joke I'm so
sorry I don't want to piss on your
bonfire but there's no dinner involved
but I'll pay for dinner Chuck best
wishes
he's gonna be so happy when he hears
that [__] message there we go
excellent uh
amazing man it's cluttered and it's
dusty damn so you've been here 10 years
what are the problems just little things
here and there that need to be updated
most of it's still from when we opened
originally so it was 13 years old now
the owner is no longer involved with the
business he's left at tweet's ex-wife
Marta Jim's ex-wife right she runs it
now with her son who's the general
manager correct right and what's his
strengths
um
tell you business-wise management wise
of Jimmy really in my opinion answering
so at this point he has the title of
general manager but I don't think he
really fully has that role of general
manager yeah he went off to train at
hotel school where did he come from no
Jimmy has no training outside of high
school
no she has no training he has no
training
who's more Hands-On Marta is Hands-On
Marta is Here There and Everywhere and
she she's like the Busy Bee that never
stops is she around
um I'm sure she's on the property let me
thank you
um I'm I'm gonna just checking around
outside and I look forward to uh seeing
Mata thank you you're welcome
hey is Marta down there
okay can you send her up Gordon would
like to meet her
[Music]
what is that thing
ugh look at all these flies
[Music]
platy how
look at that so you relax and take your
cigarette plates
oh Jesus Christ
and all these flies that is disgusting
this is a place where people come to
relax
what
ugh horrible
wow
hello hello
you must be Mara hi Marta you must be
Gordon that's right nice to see you guys
too uh what an incredible place oh thank
you it's different it looks like
somebody's spent a lot of money yeah we
did how much do you spend building this
place I think it's around 6 billion wow
and what's it worth now
oh probably two
million
um we need help Gordon uh yeah well I'm
here to help how many driveway yeah
Woodland stunning I mean absolutely walk
in there inside it's it's Kate and dust
in there supposed to be oh it is trust
me okay and then the Hamas are horror
for me was going up there have you been
up there recently uh probably about a
month ago disgusting okay flies
everywhere not a dozen couple of hundred
Okay thousands and let me give it to you
straight it looks like staff are taking
the piss going upstairs for a break
putting their cigarettes in a bottle on
the back of one really bad fire the last
thing you want to get is a second one
that's true so you're the general
manager I am running it and I'm trying
but Jimmy started a little over a year
ago right but he's so tied with the
restaurant so
Jimmy runs the kitchen and you do
everything else so that's a lot on your
part I help in the kitchen too I do the
ordering I do the ordering how come he
doesn't do his own ordering oh he would
if I told him to right yeah but
everything on your shoulders running
this place yeah I guess I'm used to it
yeah wow so um I've never done anything
like this before so it's the unfound
territory for me okay in order for me to
see where the cracks are what this place
is made of how good we are I've found an
amazing couple who have recently just
got engaged uh and due to the
circumstances with the groom he's having
to go off and do military duty in two
weeks time oh okay so they
are coming here
and we are going to host their wedding
okay when are we doing it in a couple of
days
okay and it's a very many 100 guests 100
girls okay 100 guests so I need to see
how this place functions and what you've
got what the standards are like and just
the kind of offerings okay look at it it
should have way more than 30 or 40
events a year
it doesn't make sense
knowing the castle is losing money by
not hosting as many weddings as they
should be I wanted to see how I could
improve their standards and increase
Revenue Roxanne yes
likewise hi good to see Eric how are you
so I invited a bride and groom to get
married at the castle first of all let
me say congratulations thank you I know
you're trying to get married quickly
because you're uh off yeah on duty and
so we want to make this uh somewhat
special yeah we're doing this once and
there's no rehearsal right right let's
jump in shall we okay please it's my
first time here ours too there we go
oh dear it looks like someone's pooped
on the walls uh with a lemon meringue
pie look at the ceiling
really scary cheers oh dear those are
really stinks what about spandex yeah
they're they're not nice are they that's
worse
[Music]
welcome to the castle
um let's talk about the food um what do
you normally do normally we do buffets
buffets wow that's something from the
1980s so what do we do with the tasting
the buffet we don't do tastings you
don't do tastings we don't do tastings
no why not because of the kitchen staff
the setup in the kitchen not really
selling me on a good wedding side you
can stay relaxed for now but trust me
we're going to taste some food we're
going to take a seat we're going to do
some tastings and I'd like to see a menu
um don't worry okay
too many set here take a seat please
before we do the tasting is the owner's
son here Jimmy he's the he's in charge
can we have a quick chat yeah sure okay
yeah
uh color Dreadful reception Lobby awful
the Linens don't even match there's
white and ivory and there's a lot going
on the bars I'm not sure if that's the
Dover from another Point Dreadful
Jimmy yeah uh he'd like to meet you okay
hey you uh Jimmy I'm Jimmy good to see
you nice to meet you I spoke to mum
earlier yes yes to uh two very special
guests of Roxanne hi there nice to meet
you Roxanne and Eric and Eric nice to
meet you as well
um so do you have a surf jacket or I do
did you ever wear it or um when only
when I deliver food
deliver like bring food out to people
obviously just put the jacket on to
carry food yeah so I look fancier so you
normally wear a t-shirt to cook yeah and
pants and pants yes that's very kind of
yes yeah yes anything you recommend I
mean try to sell it a little bit the
bride and groom
um
there's certain things on there I've
never made before so uh they're probably
stopped two seconds yes you've got
things on your menu that you've never
made before well no one's ever ordered
them but you run a restaurant here yes
that's not a buffet no you actually I
should definitely know how to make them
I agree yeah
I've never cooked a filet mignon before
you've never cooked a filet mignon no
who cooks it we've never sold one
so no one's ever had a wedding and
ordered filet not since I've been here
not for me you've got things on here
you've never cooked before yeah this is
the fillet correct so just out of
Interest filet mignon comes on you're
gonna go to a culinary school what
happens maybe Google how to do it
exactly
yes
yeah just to watch a video uh yes our
wedding food is really good well I can't
wait to taste it uh let's have a look at
this and okay you know I'll see you uh
later sounds good wow okay well sorry
about that after learning Jimmy gets
these recipes from the internet I'm
starting to feel like I made a mistake
inviting the bride and groom to have
their wedding here
to give some options for Roxanne and
Eric I told Jimmy to prepare a selection
of dishes up first a chicken dish I
couldn't believe was smothered in soggy
Cheese look at that we're there it's
like my grandad's foreskin
not good no wonder Grandma used to get
upset at night okay over a medium heat
and olive oil that a good heart while
Jimmy surfed the internet for how to
cook a filet mignon let the fillets oh
let the fillets eat a hot pan
we will served a salmon dish I mean we
wouldn't feed that to my cat it is Bland
it's undercooked simply draw in the
middle slimy almost and knowing Jimmy
I've never cooked a filet mignon trust
me my expectations weren't high that
steak is terrible that's overcooked
you'd cook better than that at home
wouldn't you yeah now I know why there's
no tastings available I mean terrible
terrible terrible towel I'm embarrassed
and I just want to apologize as expected
way better than this yeah I mean us too
I think yeah be patient let me get to
the bottom of this okay okay
it's clear the castle standards are low
and with only two days to put together a
wedding I'm feeling a lot of pressure
and I don't want to disappoint Roxanne
and Eric
good how are you guys feeling
discouraged I mean
you know it's an important day for us
and the food's really important and it's
like I think about this and I wanted to
be the best day of my life and then it's
disappointing something you want people
to remember for a good reason not a bad
of course exactly you know I see lots of
young couples and we host lots of
weddings but there's new territory for
me I've never seen a space member of
staff so disconnected to the real deal I
don't think we thought it was going to
be like this
there's only two days till Roxanne and
Eric's wedding and having witnessed the
lack of attention to the event space and
menu tonight I need to see how Marta and
Jimmy run their restaurant on a regular
night hey how are you TJ TJ good to see
you and this is I'm Shayla Shayla nice
to see you I'm Jimmy's wife oh Jimmy's
wife yeah his chest wife Cook's wife
General manager's wife yes right what is
he a DM or a cook a little bit of both a
little bit of both yes excellent good
answer okay good what'd you do TJ I'm
just the host Tonight excellent
so
so so
we're all [__] off Jimmy the sea bass
what about it it needs to go on it's
just what this is
uh good evening good evening hey Gordon
she has a bruschetta listed here too
success on that we haven't met yam week
no no grant Grand good to see you are
you a sous chef yes
foreign
[Music]
wow what don't you do in this
establishment nothing
[Music]
yeah I can't think anything
um
holy crap so you could call the
fisherman on the same time
uh we do the meat on the left side and
the fish on the right side
it's all the same flat yes so you're
saying everything on the left doesn't
hit the right and everything on the
right doesn't hit the left
I've never seen that okay
it's where the food sits there Shayla
yes sir why do they put food here is
this what they this is the warmers yes
this is the on the wall yes
this is what we have
it's crazy
Jesus but where's the kitchen's in there
they just stick this on the wall so
how'd you know who's is whose you just
pick up we take the wrong place all the
time what a [__] up scenario that is
what is this is this done I think so I
don't have any idea what all this meat
goes to right now what are these two
flat irons for does anybody know
here's a flat iron medium rare there's a
flat iron but I don't know what tables
they go to
Jesus
[__] me
um I've never said that is a big song
Enough was that but just
just show me that one oh a beef
stroganoff yeah yes bring it down please
yes
Charles talk to me I mean it looks like
prison food whose table is that strong
enough that's mine that's yours and what
are you waiting for now
um the rest that was uh on a single
ticket but there are six of them
seriously why is it not all the same
ticket well because they wanted separate
bills so I just I wrote them all on
separate tickets because that's how we
but you do that at the end the kitchen
needs one ticket so they can serve all
the entrees together
oh my God OMG
what are you waiting for my darling
um I was talking off
where are we at here one french fry okay
do we have anything on the six top
what's she waiting on stroganoffs I
guess
this doesn't really have any sauce in it
but you can't help it that got messed up
just take it uh you just deserve better
I'm sorry oh here's your song Enough 10
minutes later
taught too so be careful yours looks
completely different
wow what a mess what a mess
oh jeez
[Music]
Jimmy that's been sat there 15 minutes
down this one this one here what is it
yeah what are you waiting on I've just
I've never seen this kind of
dysfunctional picture so one dish three
minutes later another dish comes along
and the girls are coming up and seeing
the flat irons seeing the chicken and
just going because there's no uniform
the table's been waiting where's your
tickets right there okay
just take this medium rare flat iron
then I guess we apparently need another
Castle did we make that or not someone
must have
taken the ticket down without us knowing
it's supposed to be medium and the other
lady her potatoes garlic mashed were ice
cold oh
they want it more well done
she wants they want it more well done
the same piece or another one no we'll
have to put it back on I don't know
it gathered that the restaurant has
absolutely no organization but what is
more alarming is how dependent Jimmy is
on his mother to run this business
thank you
[Music]
we did it that was easy
uh
uh I'm not gonna laugh
just go back to the beginning driving in
and looking the place breathtaking
walking's reception and it's just caked
in dust
and that Tower in front of the entrance
is ladened with 5 000 dead flies tonight
I just want to see how this place
functioned and hand on heart I've never
seen such a dysfunctional business in
all my life
surely you must know that this is not
right
I I think we know that but you think
I I speak for myself and I can say I
know that and yet everybody walks around
us we're doing a great job and laughing
a joking as if to say we've got
something to be proud of
I wouldn't say we're in denial no
[__] I got told when I checked in
Jimmy is the general manager
can I just tell you the feeling
when you walk into this place there's no
Authority there's no responsibility and
staff are just going through the motions
and if you are even going to attempt to
step up to that position if you can't go
home pat yourself on the back saying
you're doing a great job you need to
start implementing
Gordon we would like this to be the
starting point of that you know we want
that we just you know you get a little
overwhelmed and you don't know
you know how to proceed the general
consensus in this building is that you
are generally running around seven days
a week for everybody
that's true
and tonight I witnessed it firsthand
this is no life for a lady in the 60s
nobody else banging the head against the
wall that is not right can I just have
two minutes with your mother on my own
please yes
this is insane honestly you look like
the pot washers assistant tonight I know
it's a system
yeah
I think I've gotten so used to it and so
I just keep doing it I'm not really
doing more and more every week every
month every year and it's not right
and that must be having a toll somewhere
you can't continue like this I agree has
your son taken enough responsibility
I think that I he probably feels that he
has because he's never
probably had the life that I've had to
know what it's like to work from morning
to night he's never felt the Jeopardy
that you do on a daily basis no nowhere
near it no one has and it shows he knows
you're going to do it and that's the
problem but he's got so used to that
that he's not going to come out of his
comfort zone and do any more because he
doesn't need to
no I want Jimmy to wake up and take the
burden off your shoulders and step up
and start showing some form of
responsibility
you should think about a letter about
what you need from him going forward
think about something strong and speak
openly
and if you can commit that to me
then I'm going to commit myself to you
and get in this place okay back on the
map
okay yeah
promise I promise thank you
okay get some rest okay okay
it's very important for hotels that host
weddings to not only focus on the event
itself but other services as well I'd
like to order this 79 breakfast in bed
package so I ordered a room service
package for Roxanne and Eric enjoy you
guys enjoy we will see you soon all
right
everyone
it's thought I'd check in on you how is
it it tastes uncooked oh God it's just
going from bad to worse my apologies
after seeing their disappointment and
that nothing was special about the
experience I sent someone from my team
to put together a gift basket to show
how much higher their standards really
need to be this is just basic stuff you
two dig in we've got some work to do
last night I asked Marta to write a
letter to Jimmy outlining her needs for
him moving forward I'm hoping this can
show Jimmy he needs to step up okay
um how long does it take to put this
thing together probably uh an hour hour
and a half to think about it
I want to sleep around 5 a.m what you
went to sleep at 5am why
uh
just thinking about everything that went
on and
wishing it wouldn't have been the way it
was
no one
there's a lot to fix and just being uh
completely
overwhelmed at all the aspects of it so
I have a lot of lakes like that
exactly what he needs to hear and that's
what we've got left in order to get
through to him that's where he needs to
fill your pain a little bit because
you've been too good at masking over it
yeah I yeah I do probably do that a lot
because you need to stop accepting
everything you can make things better
for yourself now and that being so easy
on your son and being a little bit more
selfish because you're too kind too
generous right I agree with that you
need a break yeah quick
yeah you're right
okay thank you
[Music]
uh Jimmy two seconds please
take a seat
your mother she left last night yes
upset I want you to listen to something
important yes I just want you to listen
okay
um dear Jimmy
I work 20 years at the coloring book
factory being on call 24 7. I of course
thought that when we sold the business
we would retire unfortunately that
didn't happen
I know you have always seen me work hard
but the financial part of it has been
just as stressful it is so disheartening
when we could get complaints about such
stupid things as dust and uncleanliness
it has to stop there's no excuse for it
it has to change
no one has more to gain by making the
castle successful than you do let's make
this place what it should be a great
future for all of us love moms
[Music]
I just want to say thank you
I know
I love it so
[Music]
you know this can't continue
and where I'm coming from it's about
stepping up that means putting mum out
of the day-to-day running are you
getting
firm
strong and making some serious [__]
decisions
I don't want to have the impression that
I'm I'm too proud or I'm a spoiled brat
because how much do you want this
I will I
don't know if there's a real word for it
but I want it I want
I mean
could I just have two minutes with him
yes please in the kitchen get yourself a
coffee and close that door
I don't [__] feel it enough
that's all I don't get uh excited by it
she
your mother hasn't got long left at this
pace and if you've got a pair of balls
she better start [__] using them and
I want you to use them quick
I don't think you fully understand just
what a gift you've got I don't think I
do either I I feel it but I don't fully
have a grip of it no and whilst I am
here I want to see you commit okay and
show me how hungry you are oh well yes
sir and when you see something wrong say
something [__] sort it out like your
mom's been doing oh well got it got it
[Music]
it's the day before the wedding and
preparations are underway normally we
have a soft drink soda station on the
antique hutch down there while the staff
discussed last minute details with
Roxanne and Eric my team and I are
completely making over the event space
we're upgrading the drab interior with a
modern Decor to brighten up the room and
create an inviting space
[Music]
are we ready can we run let's go okay
brace yourselves yeah what you're about
to see is mind-blowing jump in oh my
goodness welcome
oh my God oh my God come on in oh my
goodness
where shall we start oh my just the
lighting a lot it feels more inviting
it's a different world gone is that
ghastly yellow color oh it's beautiful
Melody oh beyond what I ever could have
imagined I can't believe it's the same
place that's awesome complete new
paneling all the way around wow
absolutely breathtaking so let's have a
little focus on the tables brand new
chairs oh my goodness it's amazing
beautiful take a seat now we have proper
elegant chairs look at the Chargers
aren't they beautiful check out the
floor brand new floor yeah so nice look
at the space over there now with the bar
so nice like it's like out of a magazine
this is what it's like during the day
can you imagine what it's gonna be like
at night with the candles yeah
is what we've needed I mean we we need
guidance and we've been spinning our
tires for so long Grace and you happy
I'm happy
I'm probably the most excited I've been
except maybe when my babies and
grandbabies were bored I'm literally
that excited oh my it's so beautiful
thank you so much yes
[Music]
now oh let's talk food
yeah ladies come line up here
I'd just take one of each menus I've got
a plan for the food let's focus first on
the menu and place for the restaurant
let's start off at the beginning french
onion soup and a bowl of chili oh wow
we've got the beef stroganoff with wild
mushrooms oh yeah next to that you've
got the chicken alfredo
let's focus on the big menu for the
wedding tonight the perfect entree is
the brace short ribs
next to that we've got a local walleye
it's amazing beautifully say it oh look
at that oh that's beautiful yeah nothing
complicated wow everything looks so
appetizing too clean yes yeah but there
is one thing missing and that's a chef
so I've arranged for a unique person
that has been working with me in Vegas
for the last five years she is
incredible and she's going to be your
consultant Chef okay let me introduce
you to Keisha
this young lady knows her stuff she's
going to help to install somebody on a
full-time basis with the Handover
process is going to be part of her
responsibility are you excited
very excited Grant work closely with her
absolutely now remember tonight you're
going to step up and run this the burden
is now on your shoulders I'm prepared to
take it
[Music]
morning hello hello gorgeous come on
ladies
amazing when I check in with Roxanne and
Eric to assure them that everything's on
track with their wedding how you feeling
very good yeah yeah I just want to give
a heads up room's looking gorgeous
okay now let's just set them up I put
Jimmy in charge of managing the entire
event from the ceremony to the reception
it's a cool area oh isn't it pretty here
with the sun coming now yeah it is
pretty while the castle has done many
events in the past I'm hoping this
wedding not only raises the bar but puts
it on the map as a destinational spot
quick here's the bride the bride's
coming everybody wow sure it's gorgeous
as they sit down let's go into the room
yeah and let's just go over everything
get the team together and we'll get our
timing it's absolutely nailed welcome
everyone to this beautiful glorious day
of the Union of Roxanne and Eric
so you guys aren't used to doing plated
service it's been Buffet after buffer
that's gone say goodbye to the 1970s
welcome to the 21st century I want some
finesse it's a wedding it's not a
funeral so be happy we're getting the
weeds we get ourselves out it's not a
race guys who's the general manager
excellent who's in charge of the kitchen
great that's right talk communicate any
uh last words of advice for the team
um just stay positive you know it's
their big day we don't want them to see
our problems yeah good luck guys yeah
thank you thank you Jim let's go I Now
pronounce you husband
wife let me kiss your bride
[Music]
[Applause]
all right everybody uh I hope you
enjoyed the ceremony we're gonna head
over to the uh The Event Hall
bright ladies help Sit Them Down got it
please quick as you can
table five right here's table 11.
who would you like I didn't do the short
ribs please so here we go Grant takes
every ticket and doesn't accept a ticket
until you understand it absolutely okay
that's the only way of course the fish
walleye okay very good okay so you've
got to synchronize with the DJ to
announce the blyden group for a big
moment this one yes okay so focus on the
timing yes yep
how are you so when you walk back in
that's when you cue the DJ yes because
the DJ is going to make the announcement
ladies and gentlemen will be upstanding
for the bride and groom yes this is a
crucial moment now yes sir I'm gonna go
up there right now and talk to him and
find out what exactly when they're
exactly coming down as soon as I come
back in the room
um you'll see me walking the door so be
kind of looking as soon as I walk in but
you have to get everyone's attention
yeah yeah what's all this for you we're
only doing the bright you want to get
their pronunciation what the braiding
room it's just Roxanna
is the pronunciation Jimmy you should
have this Nails that's what it is
I don't want to [__] up with the bride
and group okay so we have to be [__]
seamless
[Music]
I'll confirm it
is wait outside for me okay yep
oh my gosh
I'll let you tell the DJ how to
pronounce your last name correctly
alrighty you couldn't have been like the
Smiths or something all right okay so
I'm gonna go in and kind of get
everyone's attention and go ahead and
give me how do you want you would like
to be introduced Mr and Mrs Eric waldoni
the bride and groom are two minutes away
okay be careful yes ladies and gentlemen
if I could have your attention please we
have a very special couple right outside
that door and we would like to give them
a big welcome as they enter the room
let's have a nice final Applause for the
new Mr and Mrs Eric waldoni
at this time they are going to be making
their way to the dance floor to share
their first dance together as husband
and wife
[Applause]
[Music]
we're now certainly entrees just make
sure all the asparagus are lining the
same way this is the ends are together
like so yes five plates please Grant
service please that's the top table I'm
gonna give it to the bride second table
Yeah four fish two beef yes everything
look nice oh my gosh the presentation is
beautiful awesome I love it good to hear
I'll come back and check on you soon
take any plates out of your way here
you're good
Shayla why are you clearing when the
whole table haven't finished
[Music]
so his plate is cleared she's not
playing with the food yeah
of course she does so you know that so
this is what I was saying to you all
right I can't tell you the obvious
because you know this yeah okay yeah and
I want them looked after like warranty
and so do you right yes I'm gonna see if
they want any more champagne right now
yeah okay I'm gonna come back with some
champagne to top everybody off okay
the atmosphere in here is incredible it
is I mean it really is however Jimmy
needs to be on top of things right yeah
he needs to nail the small attention
details okay yeah just look at the
atmosphere the difference is night and
day yep they're happy let's keep them
that way no okay get the staff to do
that put that down okay okay you're the
owner I know you are the owner they're
asking me to go get beer and go to the
desk I'm not supposed to they're picking
up after you you're not picking up after
that those days have gone okay thank you
how was dinner I'm waiting for my wife
to a Passover
[Laughter]
how's everything tasting it's beautiful
isn't it awesome I love you
are you guys
[Applause]
you too uh my time is done uh what a day
it looks amazing seriously I mean really
have you had a good day thank you today
was perfect yeah absolutely perfect
everything that
you could have asked for
been phenomenal thank you both for your
patience because when we first met at
the beginning of the week I was more
nervous than you too
good luck to you both thank you very
much thank you
I guess huh I totally thought when we
first got here we're settling this isn't
what I want but we need to do this
quickly and now it is the fairy tale
that you think when you see a castle
it's jaw-dropping the transformation
that was made
and how you feeling first I'm feeling
great the ceremony was amazing it was
awesome who's the general manager Jimmy
is who's the owner I am that's right and
you just oversee it okay I don't want
you chasing trash cans I know when you
sweep out of the bathroom look after
yourself okay okay thank you I need 30
seconds with your son okay goodbye I
appreciate it enjoy this place I will
okay I will you deserve it thanks so
much good night good night
I do not want to see your mum sweeping
up I don't either you need to step up I
couldn't believe you've forgot the name
of the bride and groom yes that was bad
however your mind's in the right place
do not be scared of change tonight was a
little rough yeah but think of the
difference you made on that young couple
I know they seemed so appreciative of
everything and the first thing they do
they're going to tell all their friends
this amazing wedding they've had yes
you're gonna promise me you're gonna
stay on track I'm gonna put in the work
I promise good luck thank you thank you
have a safe trip thank you good night
yeah
thanks Gordon
[Music]
since my last visit landoll's Mohican
Castle has steadily increased their
bookings
Keisha has reorganized the kitchen
and with Jimmy's help they've found a
new head chef to take the lead and Jimmy
has finally taken charge as general
manager let's make a plan and figure out
what we want to do timing-wise allowing
his mother to take a step back as an
owner
oh